Es ist soweit.
Der Beginn der zivilen Raumfahrt oder anders
gesagt: In diesem Jahr wird wird es regelmäßige
Reisen für Touristen in den Weltraum geben.
Das ist wirklich der absolute Hammer!
Es geht wirklich los.
Ob wir jetzt schon alle bald zum Mond oder
Mars fliegen können.
Clixoom Science & Fiction.
Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende Sciencevideos.
Abonniert den Kanal.
Nur dann verpasst ihr nichts.
Los geht‘s.
Herzlich willkommen!
Endlich ist es soweit.
Virgin Galactic hebt in den Weltraum ab!
Es ist das erste Unternehmen, dass damit regelmäßige
Flüge in den Weltraum für Touristen anbieten
wird.
Und das war keine absolute Erfolggeschichte.
Denn eigentlich sollte dieser Menscheitstraum
schon viel früher wahr werden.
Doch es gab einen Rückschlag einen dramatischen
Unfall.
Bei einem Testflug vor drei Jahren mit der
VSS Enterprise dem Virgin Star Ship Enterpreis
gab es eine Fehlbedinung.
Das Raumschiff stürzte ab und ein Pilot starb
und weiterer wurde schwer verletzt.
Das ganze Programm musste umgestellt werden
und das Raumschiff an einem entscheidenden
Punkt neu konstruiert werden, damit das nicht
mehr passieren kann.
Schon davor kamen bei einem Triebwerkstest
2007 drei Techniker ums Leben.
Doch 2014 führte ein tragischer Fehler des
Copiloten Michael Alsbury zum Auseionanderbrechen
des Spaceships.
Für die Rückkehr zur Erde ohne Antrieb verfügt
das Schiff über ein Federsystem, das die
Flügel nach oben klappt.
Es muss entsichert und aktiviert werden.
CoPilot Michael Alsbury entsicherte es zu
früh.
Und durch die starke Strömung am Schiff wurde
es ausgelöst und Zeriss das Raumschiff.
Seitdem ging es mit Virgin Galactic nur sehr
langsam vorwärts.
Doch jetzt wagt Eigentümer Richard Branson
den ersten Flug.
Genau am 20.
Juli zum 50.
Jahrestag der Apollolandung auf dem Mond soll
es soweit sein.
Der Startschuss für die zivile Raumfahrt.
Bis dahin sollen noch weitere Testflüge absolviert
werden.
Der nächste Start ist am 20.
Februar.
Aber schon im Dezember 2018 ist ein Flug in
den Weltraum nach amerikanischer Definition
in einer Höhe von rund 82 Kilometern.
Künftige Starts sollen aber auch internationale
Standards erfüllen.
Da beginnt der Weltraum in 100 Kilometern
Höhe.
Die Riese wird jeweils dreieinhalb Stunden
dauern.
Und sechs Minuten davon befinden sich die
Passagiere im Weltraum.
Sie können sich abschnallen und schweben
im Raumschiff.
Der Raumflug wird übrigens kein Schnäppchen.
Die Passagiere zahlen jeweils 200.000 Dollar
für‘s Ticket, also rund 176.000 Euro.
Naja, da muss eine alte Oma lange für stricken.
Mehr zur fundamentalen Bedeutung der Raumfahrt
gibt es bei der Neugierzone.
Hier klicken und unbedingt abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!